[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
a judge makes a ruling in the battle to
free britney spears from a
conservatorship
controlled by her father also a civil
lawsuit against rapper y
w melli in what police say was a planned
murder disguised as a random drive-by
shooting
and another civil case in ohio's
pike county murders eight people were
killed
plus the brother of a convicted killer
speaks out about mental health
issues it's going to explode it was a
ticking time bomb for sure a jury must
decide a punishment
long crime daily covers court cases from
coast to coast
and welcome everybody july on crime
daily i'm erin keller along with brian
buckmeyer and terry austin
pop icon britney spears has for now lost
a legal bid to remove her father
as the controller of her estate an
attorney for the pop star told the judge
she's afraid of her father
and won't perform again if he's in
charge of her career
james spears was appointed conservator
in 2008 when britney was struggling with
mental health problems
in a telephone interview a judge
declined to remove the father but
partially granted the singer's wish by
naming a corporate fiduciary
as co-conservator of her 60 million
dollars in assets
the pop star's attorney called her a
high-functioning conservative
a term psychologist and law and crime
expert dr john delator explains
the idea that someone can be a high
functioning
goes completely against the idea of
gravely disabled one of the criteria
that you need in order to have
a conservator so i can see where the
public is asking for
a free britney issue though i'm not sure
if she's able to
think her way out of these kinds of
complicated issues
and perhaps she just needs someone on
her team to help her manage her life a
little bit better
but not necessarily in a legal setting
the judge said she would consider future
petitions to remove james spears as
conservator and the pop star's attorney
signaled they plan to file such papers
so
terry brian terry let me start with you
do you see that argument working a
second time around
why say well i'll consider such a move
in the future
they already made that move you know
what aaron i think there's a very good
possibility that
britney's argument will prevail the
second time around for whatever reason
the judge wants to move
in incremental steps she did already say
that they could
have a conservator as far as the
financial company is concerned she did
appoint
that bessemer trust company so i do
think that
ultimately if they make the motion again
they will be able to remove her father
as well
so brian why do it in increments why not
just say okay we're going to
do the whole thing in one hearing that's
really difficult to
understand aaron because of course we
don't know all the facts a lot of these
hearings are private so we're not
getting all the information about
britney spears
mental health the increments don't make
sense to me unless you're saying there's
going to be a change of circumstances
between one motion to the other if it's
all the same then
this really makes no sense to me as to
what the judge is doing here yeah terry
and of course that's the key part of
this what brian just said that we don't
know all the facts this was a closed
hearing we just
know the outcome that's right in private
something could be going on maybe she
can't make all of her personal decisions
so the judge wants to keep the father
there just in case
certainly terry and brian certainly
appreciate the insight on this high
profile case
actress lori lockland could be out of
jail by christmas
abc news reporting that lachlan could
soon be moved out of a
coronavirus lockdown and into the
general inmate population
at the federal correctional institution
in dublin california
because her release date is set for
sunday december 27th
prison policy allows her to back up her
release date
to occur before the weekend and before
the preceding holiday
lachlan pleaded guilty in what federal
prosecutors called the varsity blues
college admission
scandal a boxer ordered to pay more than
800 thousand dollars to a woman he
assaulted in cleveland claims he's broke
but as angenette levy tells us there's
yet another video showing adrian broner
with a stack of cash and the judge is
telling him to fork it over
boxer adrian broner spent two nights in
jail last week after failing to turn
over documents about his finances in a
civil case
broner claims he doesn't have any money
but after being held in contempt of
court and released from jail
he posted this video when my rich friend
just came back through
came back through probably hey hey man
man i only had 13 before today this
video is from broner's instagram account
this came after he posted a video a
couple of weeks ago
of a table full of cash after claiming
he was broke
the lawyer representing the woman broner
assaulted outside of a cleveland
nightclub back in 2018
asked the court to order broner to turn
over the cash to the woman
judge nancy margaret russo has granted
that request
needless to say my client is
re-traumatized every time these events
occur
because what she's experiencing is
someone
who simply defies the rule of law and
defies any accountability
and um you know this judge was very
very clear in her warning to him that
she wasn't going to put up with any
of his shenanigans and we will see where
this all leads
at this point it's not clear when broner
will turn over that cash to the court or
whether or not he'll pay it at all
he has until november 22nd to turn over
his financial documents to the judge
i'm angenette levy for law and crime
daily thanks a lot angenette
and now here's chief investigative
correspondent brian ross with what his
team is working on this week
thanks aaron coming up this week i'm
brian ross investigates
an ugly legacy of the presidency of
donald trump
inside the growth of right-wing white
nationalist extremist groups
brought to us by a photojournalist who's
been there for much of it
that's this week on brian ross
investigates on the long crime trial
network erin
thanks a lot brian and still ahead here
on law on crime daily eight killed six
arrested in a family feud in ohio the
case now heads to civil court
plus another civil case involving rap
artist ynw
melli who stands accused of criminally
killing two aspiring artists
brian buckmeyer with a live interview
when law on crime daily continues
[Music]
a civil suit has been brought against a
rap artist recruited by kanye west
and others for the wrongful death of two
of his crew members
ynw now melli whose real name is jamel
demons also faces murder charges in a
criminal court case
over the killings of anthony williams
and christopher thomas jr
police in miramar florida say demons
killed the victims in october of 2018
and staged the crime to look like a
drive-by shooting
attorney john phillips represents the
families for the victim christopher
thomas jr
in the civil suit he joins us live to
discuss the case
john hi brian first and foremost thank
you for coming here today and uh sharing
your wisdom now let's jump right into
the questions
as i'm looking at this motion you're
literally going after everyone and their
mother in this civil suit
walk me through how the claim connects
uh jamie king
demon's mother and jamison francois his
manager
right so as far as jamie king goes
she had a bit of a a battle of words so
to speak before this happened
with the other defendant ymw sackchaser
and actually said she's got bigger guns
than him he's not going to intimidate
her
and that allegedly led to the
altercation
all of a sudden sac chaser and juvie
chris thomas jr
uh are killed uh from within side the
car not from
a drive-by from without this outside the
car and
you know the question is did did jamie
king incite this
uh and then with everybody else because
it was staged
because the the items from the murder
the gun
uh the broken glass uh we're all covered
up
uh removed from the scene then we've
we've kind of expanded the circle
because we were at the end of a statute
of limitations
with a criminal case that wasn't going
anywhere fast because of covet no i like
the fact that you brought up
that back and forth between jamie king
and when she's claiming his back and
forth
um when you hear that if those claims
that the the decedent whose family
you're representing
mr thomas jr does have that kind of back
and forth do you feel that affects
this case in any way shape or form yeah
it was it was mr williams uh
ymw sac chaser that had the back and
forth with her and she
filmed a video we have it uh where she
basically said i've got bigger guns and
and threatened him
and then if you fast forward past the
shooting a month
after the shooting uh mellie releases a
video according to the state attorney
saying basically you never shut up we
got you
if you add those two videos together and
they're both
what the state attorney says they are
sounds like to me
you have a motive and an admission of a
murder
gotcha now let's go to what we're
probably going to be anticipating on the
back end of this
damages in your emotion you quote say
uh millions or tens of millions or more
are the damages i get that the jury
decides the actual dollar amount but
what's the kind of thought process of
putting that pen to paper and saying
that amount or that unspecified amount
you know
people get so confused non-lawyers get
so confused when
we allege the statutory minimum in
florida the statutory minimum is 30.
so we'll say you know damages exceed 30
thousand dollars and it's always
oh they're only one thirty thousand
dollars and so
we just kind of spelled it out uh that
that this is
millions to tens of millions depending
upon how the facts work
ultimately that's up to a jury uh but
that's
why we plan it is the way we played it
all right last question john it's a
pretty strong case
as i see it thus far is there anything
about this case that maybe keeps you up
at night and think hey i gotta think of
a strategy here
the whole thing keeps me up at night you
know it's it's
these were all really good friends that
wound up killing other good friends and
covering it up
and it's disturbing um you know we
understand mellie has
vibrant fans but there's been death
threats even
even of me um and it's
we urge peace and justice like it's
going to take some time to get the
criminal trial the civil trial over with
but it's it's just you know we got to
let justice take its
take its course all right john phillips
i want to thank you very much for
joining us here today and best of luck
uh with the upcoming case in civil suit
thank you
coming up after the break we're back to
the penalty phase of a pro baseball
player convicted of a triple murder
with a baseball bat but first a new
lawsuit against the six defendants that
lawyers say
were involved in ohio's infamous pike
county massacre
we'll be back after this
[Music]
[Music]
to a civil lawsuit in ohio's pike county
massacre eight members of the rhoden and
gilley families were executed in four
separate locations
some time later authorities arrested
five members of the wagner family
and one other relative of a different
last name
prosecutors ultimately dropped charges
against grandmother frederika wagner
when they came to believe
she made an honest mistake about
purchasing of all things
bulletproof vests all six of these
arrestees are now
civil defendants as well with me live is
attorney brian duncan who is
representing the family
and the estates of the victims brian
thanks a lot for joining us here
you're arguing in court papers that both
rita newcomb and frederica wagner likely
participated directly or indirectly
in planning the attack and you're
suggesting they conspired with the
others who are charged with actually
carrying out the attacks
how do you expect to prove that
considering the charges against
frederica wagner were dropped
well good afternoon erin good afternoon
thanks for having me on here
um whereas we we find it hard pressed to
believe that
those closest to the four individuals
that committed these
essentially mob style hits uh would have
no knowledge whatsoever
of uh of the dealings that were going to
transpire
we've essentially pled in our complaint
that we wish you know we seek to hold
all of the defendants accountable for
their actions and actions
and or omissions whether or not the same
occurred before
during or after the commission of the
crime i understand so rita newcomb was
charged with forgery perjury and
obstructing justice but she pleaded
guilty to a
reduced misdemeanor of obstructing
official business
you've suggested that you can also link
her in as well
yes um we believe that uh
those two were essentially the
matriarchs of the family and again
through the discovery process in this
civil case as well as the
ongoing criminal matters against the
four
individuals who allegedly perpetrated
these heinous acts
we believe that we'll be able to you
know create the causal connection
by and among all the defendants to show
that all of them
jointly and severally should be and are
accountable
for the murders are rita arita nukem and
frederico
wagner the deepest pockets you can also
go after as well here
i can't answer that uh you know with 100
certainty uh however they they do appear
from
our tertiary research to you know
essentially have the deepest pockets so
to answer your question yes civil
lawsuits have a lower burden of proof
than a criminal case and certainly that
runs in your favor
in this proceeding yes i would agree
with that
i believe that you know not only do we
have you know the law and the facts on
our side but also
you know the the court of public opinion
should waive favorably
upon you know myself and and most
importantly
my client uh you know the remaining
members of
the rhoden family it's been four and a
half years since those actual killings
and i hear your clients have been
frustrated because the criminal cases
are taking so long to unravel
it's uh you know i i can't speak to
you know how frustrating it has to be
for them i know for myself
you know uh from a tangential
perspective i've been involved for two
years and really there
there hasn't been much in the way of
anything that has gone on in these cases
and
you know now a couple uh coven 19
into this and yeah i mean it's uh you
know it's a slow moving process
certainly brian duncan plaintiff's
attorney in the
pike county massacre in ohio appreciate
your time here on long time daily
appreciate you and when we come back the
brother of a convicted triple murder
defendant
gives a jury a look at what went wrong
with brandon willie martin a pro
baseball player released
from a mental facility and who killed
just hours later
a former pro baseball player is now
facing a possible death sentence after a
jury convicted him
for committing three murders brandon
willie martin was found guilty of
slugging to death with a baseball bat
his father his uncle
and a security system installation man
the jury must now decide whether martin
should be locked up in prison for the
rest of his life or whether he should be
executed
kerry austin is here now to take us
through some important testimony
erin the defendant's brother sean
described what he says
was a steep decline in the defendant's
mental health
in the years before the murders the
brother described an incident where he
had to pick up the defendant
from spring training in 2012.
he just looked at me he's like sean
don't you hear them
and i was like who and he was like our
family
he was like they're talking to us right
now and
i was just like brandon i don't hear
nothing what are you talking about and
he was just like sean they're talking so
clearly
mom dad grandma grandpa and at this time
our grandparents are dead
and so it i knew at that moment it was
it wasn't good at all and when you
reacted the way you did
what was your brother's reaction to you
probably laughed probably laughed or
just stayed silent
and your brother wasn't kidding when he
was talking about hearing these voices
he's dead serious he's dead serious yeah
defendant's brother was a college
football player and said he came
home to search through the defendant's
room once to see if the defendant was
on drugs the brother found nothing but
talked about another strange
incident when i was back home training
for the pro day and i was mentioning my
brother got a dog
and so he came into the room his hands
were wet
i don't know what for maybe from water
maybe from dog pee which i hope not
but you said hey smell this and pushed
sorry pushed his hand and mushed my face
i cocked back luckily my dad tackled my
brother
and i swung and i hit the banister
and broke my hand and my mom was
standing
kind of by where our rooms were my
brother i don't know how he did this
ran behind her jumped on her put both
legs on her
and bit the top of her head and at that
moment i ran full speed
picked him up threw him up against the
wall and
at that moment i just saw just the
relief in his eyes or just something
like this
just like an awakening and it was just
he had like the most shameful face ever
he he was like oh man i messed up
one of those type of faces
martin's brother said the defendant was
diagnosed with bipolar
disorder and became more and more
unstable he said the defendant became
violent on september 15th just two days
before the murders
i woke up to my mom and my brother
arguing upstairs
and so i go upstairs and
he's just arguing with her she wants him
to go see the psychiatrist appointment
which is like at 12 or 12 30.
he doesn't want to go complaining about
his chest hurting
uh just wants to lay in bed and
at that point he when we started
badgering him on
just let out the loudest like earth
shattering yell like that i
i've never even got close to healing
hearing or feeling to this day
it set my bones and shivers and he
picked up scissors
came at us and so we call the cops
we decide that my brother needs to
needs to be taken out he needs to be
arrested or he needs to be held captive
because
this situation over the years and that
point
it just it escalated and climaxed to a
point where it was just like
man this is it's going to explode it was
a ticking time bomb for sure
so terry the defendant was taken to a
hospital but the staff released him
after 48 hours
the brother testified he rushed home
when he
heard his brother the defendant was
being released but didn't make
it in time before the killings says
tragic testimony it really is
aaron and what's more tragic is the fact
that everyone knew he had these
mental illnesses and the witnesses that
were presented on behalf of the defense
all underscored that very point we had
dr val crew who said
that she actually diagnosed him with
paranoid schizophrenia we had
amy aries who was at the facility and
she said he was in a 5150 hole
and the most really tragic testimony as
you said is from the brother who said
he was a ticking time bomb so based on
all of that you would have thought
they could predict what might happen and
they might have held him
much longer and maybe even indefinitely
ryan what does the defense do at this
point
i actually think that this was a great
witness for the defense um
the reason why i'm kind of giving pause
is because as i'm listening to this
brother describe his brother you can
hear his pain
and as an older brother myself um i
think this from a legal standpoint this
works great but also from an emotional
standpoint it really
hits home i have a tattoo on my wrist
that says i am my brother's keeper and i
see a connection with this brother as
well
as he's talking about his brother you
can tell that he was his keeper and he
was looking after him but
he couldn't help him out thank you for
joining us here on law and crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you